[Music]
foreign
about everything because no one's right
about everything but when like when
you've had a couple we've had a couple
of those talks enduring it you like you
hate them it and it's just brutal you
hate and I think it's just anybody who
you hate like when can like is it so
I like the most nine out of ten men are
mad at their dads Because they confront
us they're our mirror but they're not
doing that you hate you hate the people
growing up I hated my stepdad because he
would
break my [__] he would break whatever
move I made he was two steps ahead of me
you always don't like the people I grew
up around people that in all those years
I were [__] up at the end of the
night when I was coming down off the
coast they said listen we had a great
time and stuff
I talked to you somebody came and talked
to me they know that this guy you robbed
his house I don't mean to bring this up
but I didn't want to ruin your night
last night sleep on the couch
get up in the morning and we gotta
handle this
and they're not telling me what to do
they're not asking me what to do
they're kind of hinting to me
what the right thing to do and I get
pissed and one of the worst
conversations I ever had was with Matt
Wood and when he came up to me at the
Comedy Works and he goes why do you come
here
Ralphie 95. yeah I'm ready to kill my
ex-wife I'm living in a basement I have
no food in the refrigerator I'm
sustaining just to do blow pay my rent
and pay child support I'm lifting
weights I'm doing the right thing but
I'm gonna [__] roll every night
man I would cancel all the time the open
mic and this guy came up to me and he
goes can I talk to you for a second he's
like hey man why do you come down here
why do you waste your time in that time
he goes let me be as high as I can with
you he goes just being you you're the
funniest out of all these open mikers
God forbid you wrote a joke and God
forbid you showed up look at your
T-shirt you got a white T-shirt on you
got a white T-shirt on a dog my hands
were [__] clenching to punch this guy
in the mouth
and he goes I'm not saying nothing bad
about you you're funnier than these guys
just being you and you're throwing it
away
I know you're doing blow I know you
don't do it here but I know you don't
and this guy just read me the writer I
walked to the bus in Denver off it and
walked back to beat him up
and when I went back God let him know to
get the [__] out of there he got out of
there you know where I seen the guy
again
bumped into the guy again and 98 at the
Brave Bull
in wow in Alhambra and I followed the
guy that used to come out with the hat
and go hi my one like my wife I like my
tits with brown coffee the guy was like
a detective yeah Dwight something in the
80s and yeah the white slate no no the
lights laid the guys from Portland yeah
friends with Hicks this is a different
guy Dwight something and I followed him
and ripped the room apart and he was
back there with Brian Dunkleman oh they
had just moved to LA again man and he
came to me those basil I pulled them
aside I go Matt Wood and he hug me and
he goes that was he goes I'm really
proud I go you know why
as that talk you had with me and you
took me outside he goes I was never more
scared in my life but you had to hear it
he goes me Todd and a bunch of comics
talked about it and Todd didn't have the
balls to say something because I thought
you were going to punch me in the face I
go change my life
it changed who I am today I'm in LA
because of the [__] words you said
yeah as much as I hated him that night
you know you are in my eyes when I talk
about Headliners of this decade you're
the top guys I learned from
you have no time to slip and The
Godfather there's a line that every time
I hear it I want to punch myself in the
face and it's the [__] worst line you
could ever say
but where I come from it's true women
and children can slip men don't slip
that's it yeah women and children can
make a mistake men can't make mistakes
we we don't have I'm fear I don't have
time to make a mistake anymore
I do not have time to to to
do anything we've got handed the keys to
the castle Ralphie yeah
you and I have been handed the keys to
the cast without a doubt I haven't had a
job
in 20 [__] years
I've never had an answer to somebody
after I went to prison I didn't like a
man kicking my bed and telling me to
wake up all right I haven't had an
answer to somebody well I haven't had an
answer to somebody since I was 15. but
for a job to make a living
and somehow it came together even when
you were in your [__] apartment yeah
it always came together as long as you
were out every night right you were
writing every night you [__] hustled
right every day I work every night is it
scary when you see like how close it is
like so I just did that that seminar and
now I'm trying to start doing more more
of them and I wasn't even really scared
before the first but now that I'm like
oh I could I could see my I really
enjoyed doing it and now that I can see
not that it's going to be easy but I I
can see that but it's possible like
after you guys do shows you see that
it's possible and you know that there's
a ton of work to put in like for at
least for me it got scarier I think what
your Market needs right now and this
guy's a genius of getting the business
for you but I think right now what
you're doing [__] these little comedians
I think if they're going to start a
podcast they're going to start a podcast
they know how to do it okay I think
you're people it's like computer people
yeah protect people people who really
are uncomfortable they don't know this
world and they want to learn it from A
to Z comics know this world
they have friends that are doing this
right now every comic is doing this
right now okay it's uh it's a it's you
go you're going after pennies when you
go after dollars it's just gonna take
you a little work but when you strike
one of those companies you're gonna hit
Oh you mean go after companies okay go
at the [__] a t and go how come at T
doesn't have a podcast every week yeah
that's crazy talking about their
services and what's going on with phones
and technology and like answering people
and answering people's problems and [__]
yeah that's what a doe is right now
that's your next move that's who's at
home going right now there's a board
meeting going we're losing 22 because
we're not computer uh we're not yeah
Savvy Savvy yeah what is going on tell
us about it look at [__] Amazon
Amazon today is getting slammed by
[__] [__] work conditions for people
I mean they're keeping people working in
[__] warehouses over 110 degrees with
no breaks they time everything they need
some [__] counter that [__] I mean I
don't want to buy Amazon now I mean but
if if they would have a podcast that can
explain it and tell me hey the air
conditioning broke you know maybe I
don't know the full context maybe the
full context is not being reported you
know those [__] news agencies there's
always a [__] by the way I'd like to
hear the other guys [__] side of this
[__] all right and that's exactly what
they need please
I'm sitting here across from you
and we'll end this podcast in a couple
minutes but I got to tell you something
it's uh
I'm 52 man I've had a great life I laugh
I love thinking and being upset and
laughing I live to laugh people I know
sometimes I come across as a prick I
love giggling and I love laughing
I have a lot of regrets in my life I did
a lot of [__] up things I was talking
about my godfather before
one of the biggest regrets I have that
we didn't have the money to do Ralphie
what a mistake that
what a mistake that we could go back and
rewire
that apartment with a camera oh my God
we would have a show and I'm telling you
that would have been the all time it
would be HBO's all-time greatest comedy
show and you can't and you know what I'm
sitting here across my mouth and I'm
listening to a story and I'm like
I can't even go to HBO like I'm
sometimes I'm thinking of Ralphie not
reading a show about Adventures of a fat
guy
just even the rest of the tube when you
fail that time oh filing on Gardner
listen I'm sitting here
okay I think not even Gardener the thing
you were telling Lee about that he's
going on you don't understand
this chick he's this chick is living in
his house before we're talking about the
story here's three guys trying to [__]
the same chick
it's miserable
but you wanted to [__] if your face fell
into that [__] it wouldn't be anyway
wouldn't have been right this Lisa
Lisa this is an apartment that's living
on whatever round for his Society I'm
living off Ralphie I got a little bit of
Coke in my pocket Ralphie's making
bloody Mary with Bloody Mary's and we're
going over there we're hitting this
every night everybody knew that at two
in the morning
the Red Devil Ricky Cruise
you know and we just talked about
producer somebody would have a joint
somebody wouldn't have a joint but this
one night it was just me
drinking Bloody Marys and we're giggling
and Jody says something to Ralphie to
piss them off and there was a big
Japanese lamp in the kitchen all right
and [__] over here sits down and she
pisses him off and he sits in the
position and something happened that the
light got a little lower and he's
[__] saying [__] to her with his face
red right he's like [__] you this is my
life
don't you ever talk to me like this this
is my [__] house you believe this
Coco she's my guest and she's talking to
me like this this is my vodka something
and he in the middle of his rage he's
like ah and he stops because the light
bulb is burning his head it burned my
hair you can't write that you cannot
write that that's inspector Clues though
type [__]
for like three weeks I was like Junior
just wolf
did that toilet in your house no no no
no no
you [__] up
and you also [__] and give a shower and
then push it down [__] Okay I
know the real you Coco all right you can
[__] with these other [__] but I'm
Bonafide okay I was there at the
beginning okay
lighting the bum on fire
eating people's [__] if that apartment
building had a [__] camera oh my God
we would be multi Millions millionaires
I tell the story of the night I brought
shamer there and she was giving these
people a drug dealers wanting to [__]
Sheamus oh so I left it downstairs in
Gavin's apartment
and she's dancing ESPN stories and I
come back at five and there's one guy
I'm horrible yeah
[Music]
shut up [__] dance take them titties
out okay that's what she told her do you
remember that he's a [__] told her
because yeah whatever [__] take them
titties out
[Music]
she dances at a [__] lesbian Ball but
she keeps marrying gay guys by mistake
what she hooked up with that dude in
Alaska I had to do this what listen to
me about 15 years ago I gotta do this
again
listen to me I had to do this gig in
Alaska one time it took it Charlie's and
at one of those for one of those people
and I canceled I got like the stupid TV
show or something for NBC and I had to
cancel and she went up there and met a a
go-go dance like a
a male dance and they fell in love and
she put his name on her little [__]
and they were in love man he was like
wow he was like unemployed but he always
came up a little bit of money and she
was dating him for like two years they
were in love and then one day
she wanted his email she saw an email
from old dudes that would he would go to
their house in the afternoon and put
like a bikini and he would dance for old
dudes and [__] and he would get like 50
bucks and do meth so she threw a
mountain she was heartbroken because she
always makes [__] up choices I've told
this story before yeah somebody tells me
this is the this is the name of the guy
that she's got on her [__] this guy is
a go-go dancer for old dudes and he's
smoking meth so she throws them
no no
I bumped into her and she says to me how
you doing blah blah we're going back and
forth
hey
and I knew it was I don't know what the
guy's name was beat on me though so
how's Mark doing and she gets kind of
sad she goes I'm not with Mark anymore
that's a shame I go listen I know this
old dude
[Laughter]
either way you Gotta Give It Up to her
she is a creative of a ball buster she
will give it but she will [__] take
it I tell you what she takes it better
than a lot of [__] vote about no man
she's always
[__] funny she came up at the comedy
so she came up in a [__] Comedy Club
her mother's a biker her mother's Gemma
did you know that her mother's like
Gemma like she was telling me stories
showing me pictures one time in the
house her mother's like Gemma and she's
half Arab I didn't know that yeah she's
Arabian she's like uh Jesus Iranian
she's beautiful
you think that she had plastic surgery
and you're like but you realize it's
just natural she flows it all enhances
you you're on a roll you're smoking
you're smoking and also I'm smoking the
cigarette in the back alley of
1440. okay
okay
but this is no this is yes this is
across the hall okay so the windows open
I'm smoking cigarettes like a
[__] I'm smoking cigarettes I'm
chasing joints with cigarettes you know
me
it's 9 30 in the morning I'm on the
third joint I'm on a pack of cigarettes
and [__] camel lights
and I'm throwing these cigarettes out
the window half lit on fire right
[Music]
and all of a sudden you hear ah
ah now I did not know there was anybody
out there I hear ah
I go what the [__] and I keep hearing
this ah who the [__] lit me on fire and
I'm sitting like a whole light somebody
and like I did and I look out the window
and there's the guy [__] smoking his
shirt or something his clothes are
smoking the poor [__] guy I go home
the cops don't come nobody knows nothing
I'm an El Compadre that night get in the
package it's about 10 o'clock at night I
walk back and there's the same homeless
guy with a blanket on and you can see
where the cigarette birth and it just
caught on fire and went
on fire
please
I was right across the hall the fire
department did come by
probably somebody just driving through
that [__] alley flicked it on him
[__] him oh my god get that dirty bomb
the [__] out of our house guys I feel
bad a little bit once I saw the blanket
I felt a little bad one time did you get
a new blanket at least one time
I'm lucky I had a blanket myself I was
snorting my blanket I was about to snap
my pocket I had a choice a a blanket
oh my God I had a blanket that I can't
believe you just brought up a blanket
okay let me tell you something
let me tell you something though in
1983. it was maroon on one side and tan
on the inside the one I had yeah the
lion the brown one yes okay let me tell
you something about that brown [__]
Lion Okay let me tell you something
interesting times a week
that brown lion I got that Brown Line at
a Kmart
this uh May of 1984.
that's it
it took me five years but I did I got my
own apartment
and I got an apartment on 48th Street
46th Street North Bergen 44th Street
I got a one bedroom Studio on the first
floor when I didn't pay rent they could
sneaking through the front window was
perfect I was there for about four
months five months
but right before I moved in there I
wanted to go straight so I bought this
blanket in 1995. I mean there was no no
9.99 it was the cheapest [__] 9.99
oh
I watched that blanket I got evicted
from that place I was homeless I went to
California and came back I caused Wars
that summer went to Miami came back the
whole time that that blanket was at the
bottom of my travel bag
I had an army bag
and that [__] thing was at the bottom
some places I went they had a blanket I
didn't use it I always had a blanket
like a biker you ever see a biker Yeah
man they always got a blanket I had that
[__] blanket
I had that blanket when I was living in
the [__] rocket ship
I would take it back to the Runnings and
put it in a little corner and leave it
in there that night go take the [__]
blanket when I moved into the hotel
in 84 when I was homeless and I got into
the hotel I went and got that blanket
and when I beat Joelle for the 1500 I
had that blanket I took that blanket
with me that blanket was with me from
the desolate time of my life in that
rocket ship
to
199 [__] nine when that [__] car
got towed
that car that blanket was even with me
when I went to prison I left it in that
room and nobody [__] touched that
blanket
that blanket was 9.95 in 1984.
and I had that blanket for what 15
[__] years yeah and that blanket was
doing the warmest blankets I ever it was
a bear
okay and on the inside it was the bear
with brown and yellow and on the outside
it was the bear with yellow and brown
you follow me yeah and then the outside
of it was [__] Brown so for 9.95 at
[__] Kmart I bought a blanket that
went through [__] hell with me and
back Jack a marriage a divorce
when we were married she wouldn't she
wanted to throw it away you know [__]
ever throw that [__] thing away that
thing was in Miami I slept behind a
[__] McDonald's with that thing what
because in those days I would just take
the [__] of clothes out of the army
bag take the [__] blanket out put the
clothes back in use that as a pillow and
put that blanket on top me G that was an
all-purpose army bag I had I had a
little bit of water I had a razor blade
for blow I had a [__] wrench in there
if I had to break a window for a car oh
no no Lee that that [__] blanket was
there with me and that blanket I would
just wash it
all that blanket wanted was my love and
I lost it when that [__] car got
throwed in Van Nuys it was in the trunk
of that [__] blanket that that
blanket was on the roads with me all
those years on Triple runs whenever I
got a hotel room that blanket came into
the hotel room I threw the blanket off
and I used that [__] blanket have you
looked for it online
the same blanket yeah it wouldn't be the
same Lee why would I want the same
blanket it wouldn't be the same that
blanket was with me through [__] Wars
when I lost that car that was the
hardest thing about that though
oh my God that that car got towed like I
thought it was is that the car that I
got my car towed to get all your [__]
out no it wasn't that time no no no no
no this was a car then mainly gave Josh
Wolf yeah yeah I got you yeah I got you
no I never got my [__] out of it it was
nice I got at my car towed to get all
your [__] out because they wouldn't let
you in the lot yeah but they wouldn't
let me in the car it was [__] crazy
all I could get was the back seat and
some of the front yeah no no it was
nothing head shots boxing gloves oh yeah
blankets [__] pictures when I was a
kid I had [__] in that [__] car they
took and uh sometimes sometimes you know
till this day I was just thinking of
that blanket yesterday though in Jesus
Christ how long did I have that goddamn
blanket for I wish that
that blanket [__] I would have taken it
to the next eternity with me that's how
that's what that let me tell you how
deep that blanket went
in 1985 in February 1985 I looked at
that blanket one then I go there's
something wrong with that blanket there
were crabs on that blanket I had crabs
and gave it to the blanket you
understand me who the [__] gives crabs
to that blanket I did where's Tony
Bennett
hahaha
it's 55 for standing room only at The
Canyon Club for a YouTube tribute band
okay oh my God so okay who would pay
that I don't know I gotta get their
[__] emails no [__] them [__]
morons oh my God I went to see the two
oh my God they were they were so amazing
oh my God they're just tricking people
like me who didn't know yeah you'd be up
there
[Applause]
uh they want 250.
oh
[__] Roseville is [__] huge man
it oh was it was a whole 60 000 70 000.
oh my God I'll hold on one second yeah
look at the price of these tickets
this is California and for and that was
for general admission below up top they
went I'm sorry 4 30.
I guess maybe that's a better angle I
don't know yeah
oh my god do you want to confirm this
just think something make sure no no
you're on the Rose Bowl that's that's
the right I mean I was like 55 I don't
think so whereas down oh dude this is
why I'm watching cheers this is like
okay leave me alone leave me alone well
no I'm saying it's the same thing at the
same time period in a way what time
period not exactly but like they're
listening to YouTube on Cheers no well
maybe 80s 90s I don't know I don't know
when YouTube is are you playing with me
I don't know when you two is around are
you really trying to drive me crazy when
was you two started YouTube the last the
first time I'm about YouTube is maybe
82. no you okay 82 or 80. so yeah they
were listening to YouTube somewhere out
there so they were what they're so good
dude they're really [__] good man
really like you too oh my God yeah and
they [__] blow it up in concert
you'll sit there and [__] drool it
seems like Bono wouldn't would annoy you
he got annoying he got on my nerves on
one of the tours He Walked on stage with
a cane and [__] let it go okay
yeah [__] off but you know what man he
shows he's like he shows up and he
delivers the goods and the guitar player
is a Savage the bass players The Savage
the drum is a [__] Savage
nobody
I know I love music I like I like me I
like what they do I like the early [__]
I like some of the [__] they play on the
radio sometimes I mean I wouldn't go buy
it if that's what you're asking me but I
like it
I really like the Joshua Tree but I
ain't paying 250 at the Rose Bowl for
[__] seats and it's 50 to [__] Park
and it's not in a beer you know what
I'll buy the [__] CD and put it on my
iPod and the next time I take a five
hour flight I'll drop purely Stars yeah
and I'll do it for [__] free man
those dudes are those Stars need to hook
hook up me up those are great well with
a [__] email you can take the stars
with you you know [__] love like you
want another one [__] yeah [__] yeah Lee
here's one for you oh sure why not
there's three of them we might as well
[__] yeah [__] yeah come on Lee oh [__]
wow
can I have another water please no more
water
I have some of that thank you
why can't you just swallow it
I don't think so
it tastes pretty good
and what he's got about puke watch this
he gets [__] just trying to eat
waffles
I like them I love these drinks oh my
God these are that I love I personally
what do you think Ralphie I think
gummies are the number one edible for me
yeah
that or the oh breast strips did you
ever try those I came out after the
brush straps I didn't oh my God those
look great I know they extinct for sure
yeah nobody's got them they're just one
place still got them
really right there in Santa Monica
if not they should I'd go in and buy
them out man I'd go in there and drop
two thousand dollars on those
I mean that's a whole that's the whole
point within Edibles is just to get it
over with to do it quickly to not have I
mean I I don't I like smoking I don't
mind smoking but it just doesn't last
long enough for me
so Edibles I I think that's that's why I
don't like like the big cakes and and
the cereal bars some people do they're
obsolete those things yeah they're
obsolete those big things oh my God I
don't think anybody's making cakes
anymore no no there's a company that has
them remember the guy showed up here one
day right yeah and he had like really
delicious stuff but
60 milligrams I'm wasting 3 000 [__]
calories yeah no way it's not worth the
aggravation it's a [__] huge piece of
chocolate cake they got it so but then I
don't see baking Goods anywhere no and I
generally go to fourth place I got that
place Buds and Roses I got perennial I
got the Russians number one and I got
the people over by Victory there and I
don't see those I don't think there's no
more banana bread
you know the stars are seven calories
yeah
seven [__] calories you don't even
know this in your system at night you
wake up to pee at two and it's real
yellow with that said it's glowing in
the dark you wake up wow and the morning
go oh [__] that star has some kick to it
yeah that [__] mule look at that
toilet it's shining this [__] it looks
like that [__] in the [__] what's the
Old Man movie the [__] they stole from
the Moon and put in the pool what's that
movie with cocoon oh cocoon yeah
exactly glows like a [__] and [__] yeah
right you wake up at two you pee with
little stars of death you're like oh
that kidney is working overtime Jack I
know we're putting the strain on those
[__] this must beat steroids
and kill that [__] liver
speaking up Ralphie joey yes Joey has
tried to uh or doesn't try he does
torture me
recently with his boogers and I think I
I I I I I think you must have been
around at that time
has he have you ever seen him eat a
booger who Coco eat a booger yeah no no
no my favorite Joey booger story is we
were at The Comedy Store in like 2 000
okay and me and Joe Diaz were the only
ones smoking weed okay up there they're
a bunch of lamos it just wasn't it me
and Coco were it and we kept on getting
the ear beating from this black guy who
said he was a a producer from Fox he was
just doing this to come into the shows
he probably wasn't even a a PA a
production assistant you know this guy
was there and it was so [__] annoying
and telling us about what TV show we
should do and stuff like this and Coco
I I guess he had a head cold and the
boogers the boogers he was pulling out
lay they were they were like hard at the
at the at the beginning and then like
really thick and wet at the end I've
seen it okay you know what I'm talking
about those they're they're amazing it's
like half Triscuit half snail okay all
right and he'd take those and and he'd
go to the sky and and like and rub them
in okay that guy must have had 20 000
snots on the back of his jacket by the
end of the night Coco I saw this one too
late he got one going on one finger all
right and then went with the other
nostril with the thumb with the thumb
all right and so he had two and that one
that one looked like a [__] seagull
[__] on that guy's shoulder it was so
thick and it was amazing and this guy
was such a [__] [__] it was the
most tremendous I used to put snots on
my head school teacher Mr zinc I used to
hang out with a daughter he used to wear
the same black jacket every day and once
or twice a week ago I'm coming top on
the show and say what up Mr zinc and his
back had [__] thousands a little
drive that's nice he would never wash
the jacket it was just yeah
that plus not on a few people but that
guy the producer was the [__] best
man you don't go to focus on the yellow
focus on the yellow it's rather than
everything now he sees it now you see it
right I I can feel it I'm not freaking
out though I I can feel a cake it's
definitely kicking in I like it I like
ass I'm not like it's just I swear
yellow yellow yellow just yellow baby
yellow that's all I'm thinking no other
colors just yellow all right that's it I
like y'all yo what's my favorite color
stay in the middle stay in the zone baby
especially when I came out here I go how
long is it gonna take
for me to [__] up like how long was it
gonna take for me to
hit somebody with a chair
Rob one of these comedy clubs yeah
because you can just sit there and look
at ten thousand for so long for so long
before you have to smash Mama me if it
was anybody else's wedding
it's like
you know it's like it's like it's so
crazy how you we sit here and we [__]
around
and you crack jokes but how sad is it
that like
Keith Richards I'll live [__] Whitney
Houston oh yeah like like Ozzy
Osbourne's outliving everybody I know
and he's still doing blowing pills she's
tried to dump them two months ago
because he was still getting [__]
high and [__] the hairdresser how old
is this guy they don't stop what people
don't realize is I just figured this out
too me and my my tour manager Ben we
were talking about this how the [__]
Ozzy you not understand a goddamn word
he says but but sings like a [__]
bird how the [__] did that ever happen
Lou Graham the English people that's
what they do them [__] bad as a bone
check I'm sorry I'll cut you out no no
I'm just thinking about how these people
you know I sit here and I go how the
[__] did I live Whitney Houston like
especially during the Martell cartel day
yeah and I always felt bad like
I I never knew when the trust was gonna
end like I never knew at what point I
didn't know if it was going to be being
on the road with Mark Babbitt one day
you know like and him being no no
because when I do it I heard he's lost
all his teeth yeah when I first moved
here he used to uh book these shows with
Carlos and and uh and uh
when what's his name was still very hot
what's the Mexican guy the you know the
Paul Rodriguez and he was born George
Lopez yeah George Lopez I mean that was
Mark rabbit Mark Babbitt was driving
back to Texas with 30 40 G in cash yeah
because he was he would take the money
from the safe at the last stop
and use it to finance his tours
she was at a millionaire she's somewhere
is she still alive no no no he he bought
it I mean he didn't buy it he didn't buy
it it was it was a old lady who owned no
no no you were thinking of uh of the
Austin woman right what was the name of
the lady in Boston because Pete was his
stepson or something yeah yeah right and
um uh she was uh she owned a bunch of
country bars but she just thought it was
a good manager and her G-Body she bought
it from um uh the uh uh Sandy Marcus
okay and Sandy and her husbands are the
ones who started the last stop and then
Sandy soda when she wanted to get out to
this uh lady who was a
multi-multi-millionaire probably worth
probably 100 150 million dollars more
because she owned like The Men's Club
she owned the biggest country bars she
had a majority of steak and Gillies when
Gillies was hot and [__] Urban Cowboy
this this woman had so much [__]
money and this was just one of her
things and she liked comedy but she
wouldn't even come in and that's how she
got paid in there but before pig man
with three hands Mark Babbitt was taking
money out of that place so he was taking
the money out of the bank and then he
was throwing what I was doing as a kid
you borrowed 25 Grand on Friday
as long as you have it back Monday
before the bank opens
you went back 30 grand like I said I had
a friend who worked at a bank in the
early 80s that was the deal Friday at
three Monday at nine you better have my
money to put back in that [__] bank
vault but I'm getting five grand off the
top and he did it every [__] week
this kid yeah but he could never be
light on a Monday he only
wow you couldn't do that now no [__]
way no no [__] way you can do that
now let me tell you how good they had it
wired this kid that I'm talking about in
particular
I knew him I grew up with him and one
time when my mom died he worked at a
bank
and like I was telling his younger
brother I got these checks I got this
credit card he goes talk to my brother
oh come on bro so I called the brother I
met him I gained the two checks the
credit cards he calls me two days later
meet me at next
so it's you know my mother just died
they had just shot John Lennon oh wow it
was just the week when they shot John
Lim like they shot John Lennon on a
Monday Night Football yeah during Monday
Night Football I picked up that envelope
on Tuesday
like I gave him those checks on Saturday
yeah and the next day when I was in
school his brother came up to me and
said call my brother he wants to talk to
you about something I called him up he
goes meet me up at next eight o'clock I
went up there he gave me an envelope
that was four inches deep
all [__] bills were 100 my mom was
dead but will this take care of what
things for a while forever forever I got
I got that money and I put on the mic I
moved him with his family and I moved on
and I put the money under my underwear
and they would never [__] know I
would just
it was like it was like a real ATM
machine
like I hid my jeans on top of it yeah
and I would just dip my hand under and
take a hundred dollar bill and go out at
night wow like that's how spoiled that
was like that at that point you never
thought about saving any of it oh yeah
oh yeah I thought about saving it and
yeah
I was 17 years old yeah yeah okay yeah
I'm gonna invest in what getting a
[__] yeah
Gabby that's what I'm gonna invest in
Lee there's no Investments Lee you took
that you took that to the bar and you
invested you you would have had
something for a [__] up late sure is
it is that not only did he just say oh
that was fine he was still working all
right him and his buddies they would
they would drop out of trees on
unsuspecting gay guys and beat them like
gorillas tell one thing one unsuspecting
gay guys they were
perverts perverts and pedophiles do not
know what they wanted to do yet because
listen man those guys would drop out of
the [__] trees like gorilla
let me tell you something my friend just
went to my friend just went to my friend
just went to the mayor's bar to my
buddy's ball yeah he's done
friend just went to my buddy's ball on
Friday venary yeah had his first ball on
Friday 175 a ticket oh wow why does he
have a ball like for his like because
he's a commissioner oh he's an
assemblyman I love it and uh he told me
that the guy we used for bait as kids
was dead I go how does he look he goes
bro
that dude has an aged a [__] day he
said he still looks like an Italian
model oh wow we used to take this kid
and the reason why we used them is
because he had a connection
I know that if we ever got arrested this
[__] would get squashed at the end right
before they're really impressed charges
this kid had too much juice right that's
the reason why I used to take him I'd
split right 50 50 right down the middle
but all he had to do was just bait
that's all you got to do is just bait we
did the [__] kicking in the pool
all right so so to explain to him okay
so he'd be out there and then horrible
horrible
fun time
you're gonna say that did you ever say
that to yourself like someday when you
guys will be 50 y'all that was a
terrible horrible
fun time in my life
it was that dark and terrible like it
was like if I think about it now it was
dark like even the daytime it was dark
like there was no sunlight in my life
that and it was my my it was like my
junior year it started my sophomore
summer going into junior year where you
heard Rumblings there was this uh Davey
Thomas this Thomas family and they were
the kings of it the family who owned
Wendy's stay with it
these kids did not always
and they were the first ones that 64th
Street crew were the first ones that
started going up Boulevard East and then
the word started getting out you can
make some money if the a lot of people
drive lift now oh yeah that's how it was
then yeah man on the boulevard Easton oh
my God like that's how [__] it was so
well a spare change but you know what's
crazy when I read when I read The
Iceman's book and I read The Iceman's
book yeah oh my God the Iceman used to
live in West New York New Jersey
and he said that in the 60s he would
just kill people from practice
on Boulevard East get the [__] book
he goes I can't he goes I really
couldn't give an actual account of how
many people I killed
because that was three years I was just
practicing he goes I can go to a bar on
the west side yeah and tell a guy I was
gay or whatever and he'd follow me to
Jersey and I kill him on the Jersey side
and [__] he goes just for practice just
to practice control tactics oh my God
this guy was the real [__] deal why
do you read this book this book sounds
like a terrible no it's fascinating it
was very fascinating let me tell you
something why do you look good Tigers
when the Iceman popped up 10 15 years
ago like people called you the next day
yeah it was [__] disturbing yeah it
was disturbing like even the first time
I watched I'm like because you live near
him or just no no no no it was
disturbing that
I always thought that you kicked someone
in the stomach and you had some fun and
you call them a [__] this guy had
it
this guy had it to a completely
different level what was he doing he was
a hitman that
forget the whole [__] story he was
working on a porno thing yeah he was he
was editing films that's right editing
films and the guy wouldn't pay him and
uh and uh he [__] whacked him
and then he threw the girl off the roof
I mean the whole family's rotten oh my
God the family was rotten to the core
the when I when you read the book
there's times you're reading the book
you have to shut the book and go away oh
my God his first wife dumped him and he
cut his nipples off yeah I remember you
told me that story he caught a nipples
yeah and he used to he used to live
right there with a coat factory when we
were kids that was it we weren't buying
the coal fight if you go to the Coat
Factory today and vacuum it you're gonna
find rocks of Coke from the 80s I wish I
was kidding it was every night you knew
that if you were gonna come over and you
want to get Coke and you was coming from
the city go to the Coat Factory there'd
be four cars there and somebody in that
car had to blow something behind a tree
behind the dumpster somewhere in this
area there's an ounce of [__] Coke
wow yeah that the first interview with
the Iceman was very fascinating what
happened was Leif that people took that
interview sucked it in and then started
hearing other things and also put them
together and they were all really tied
together
all like different stories oh no all the
mafia hits were tied through him oh yeah
he began doing uh hits for one family
and then he kept going to different
families and yeah he really hits for
different captains and nobody knew what
the [__] he was doing then he got really
crazy the third phase of it is he got
really crazy and he started saying that
he was there on every murder like when
Kennedy got shot I was up the corner
yeah
when uh the guy from the [__] bananas
got shot that's Joe Mary's Restaurant in
Brooklyn and that summer he says he had
one of the tables that he was one of the
backup Shooters if the original shoot is
[__] up that's a lie you know what I'm
saying yeah these that was an inner
family thing they weren't going to get a
[__] [__] they're stepping on that
one there was just a lot of things he
claimed but at the end he said something
that I've said on here you know all
these people like conspiracies
you have no [__] idea I can make your
day I can say you leave you need a VCR
yeah give me a hundred bucks because I'd
use The Travelers checks
it would cost me nothing
The Travelers checks have cost me
nothing okay 30 cents on the dollar
maybe maybe a favor
like in those days the Cubans used to
get a ton of Travelers checks but they
couldn't use them because they didn't
speak English
so I was the only [__] that I
upload so they'd tell me what they want
up in Japantown and I get it for them to
charge them a vague for doing it for
them like go 50 on them and what were
they gonna do they couldn't use them
themselves they couldn't even speak to
[__] life oh my God
[__] crazy that's right this is the
[__] that keeps me up and how do you
come up with this stuff as like just on
the Fly make these business like it's
you're running a Empire you're out there
you're a one-man Army on a daily basis
you wake up in the morning you go to a
charties you order breakfast and you put
it on a tab and you tell them you're
gonna be back by five
and let me tell you something you want
to know about pressure when you put
breakfast on the [__] tab and You're
Gonna Come Back by five with ten dollars
so I got to make time I'm already minus
ten it's nine a.m I gotta put this
[__] day together here I gotta do a
half gram tonight it's ladies night at
[__] Apollo I'm gonna come up with a
new shirt I gotta go to [__] Walmart
in those days
somebody's getting robbed today
oh what a [__] nightmare you have no
idea Lee you have no [__] idea I'm
very happy that whole [__] today I was
talking to Larry when we were talking
about something we're talking about
businesses and he goes what if you just
took the little business and moved it to
Vegas and I don't explain something
that tall borrowing from Peter the
people eventually you have to think they
got an area on something they're going
to realize you don't live in Vegas or
some [__] and you're gonna go away
that was me 35 years ago yeah yeah [__]
it yeah let's do it who gives a [__]
with no repercussion at all it's the
repercussion that [__] kills you
right yeah I had when I moved in I
didn't transfer my electric it was just
on I had it for like a year and a half
and they just turned it off one day
I had to go in I think they end up being
like fourteen hundred dollars
well you gotta know Jesus you know it's
funny how poor Matt Becker
I quit High School
that
August like that August before my senior
year yeah I was like there's no sense of
me going back oh my kid
my life
like I was at that point like a woman go
to school yeah I go this is a job it's
Union they promote from within right
these guys make money I knew all about
this company because I had worked for a
lumber yard that was a mass back Century
Hardware chain this was the warehouse so
I would talk to the guys that delivered
all this [__] and they were telling me
how much they enjoyed working there and
one day I realized it was down the block
from where I was living and I went from
being a daytime shift guy to a nighttime
loader
I'm making 15 an hour
this ain't bad at all I could do this
forever this takes me [__] four hours
at night
and you know what bro I went back like
in November and I picked it out I tried
to do all the credits and they came back
to me they said you're not going to
graduate on the stage
and I said then what the [__] am I doing
this for yeah
and I don't get invited to anything I
know nothing nothing either listen guys
I'm over it already like I know right
it's like I have to be over it
I miss a lot of those people first of
all no no but I talked to a lot of those
guys yeah I don't see I talk to a lot of
those guys especially now lately
the last few years in fact I want to
give a shout out to my buddies have an
open heart surgery
[__] Wednesday if
I didn't have Brea this weekend
and my wife didn't pick if my wife
didn't pick Tuesday tomorrow to fly
I would have [__] uh
flown back to New York at least Monday
yeah this guy went to my mom's wake wow
like I go back that deep with it with
Stephenville and his family and [__] so
I'll be praying for my Wednesday open
[__] heart
surgery
plays in a band
went home one night I got rushed to the
hospital his heart was beating too much
don't do drugs yeah yeah hasn't done a
drug in 20 [__] years then it
happened again he had an episode again
so they said they have to do something
to his valves so wow but I was all four
years at that kid that's [__] amazing
35 years and guys you're listening to
this podcast like what the [__] is Joey
talking about let me tell he was talking
about it goes fast [__]
it goes way real fast
real fast I know next year I know
Ralphie 20 years right yeah 98 that's
how fast
this [__] knows I know Ralphie
from an apartment they're getting a dog
they're getting married they're having a
big house they're having two kids
they're having two houses and a bus and
a bus now back to one house or no houses
it's [__] Reno Tahoe and back to the
ghetto
so lucky dude the guys at Caesar's are
just treating me super nice now you know
I mean it's it's phenomenal they're
Class Acts you know and I can't I can't
be mad the way I'm being treated or
nothing I can't even gripe well listen
brother
like I tell people all the time that
you said it when we were talking earlier
about there's no escalator to the top
you know you're not getting paid right
now you're getting paid for this [__]
you did when you went up to Visalia and
your [__] keys fell down the elevator
oh my God I remember
okay you know who does that happen to
her uh lee who is that what happened to
me that you go to a [__] gig you do a
great job you spent the night you wake
up the next morning you go to the
[__] elevator you go oops your keys
go down that one little crack that crack
and I heard they help like a minute yeah
I heard they held by the time
I could see them I could see him going
down as they hit the light of every
elevator so I saw him and I could see
him down bottom
bottom I'm just like ah I got hit by a
kid who's coming in from the swimming
pool okay and I had the keys in my hand
and I got hit by that little girl and on
my hand and boom they just right in the
middle it took two years but the Hilton
there or the Marriott whatever it is
they uh they gave me my keys back but
luckily I had an extra key in the car so
all I had to do was get it over and it
was Saturday and they couldn't get
another minute guy no I mean there was a
thousand [__] by the ways yeah and
that's why I tell you know everybody
like young Comics like the other dad
bumped this summer dude when I was with
my family and on the way out he goes oh
you know I've seen you at the comedy
store I just got into it I've been doing
it a year because what is it what is it
can you tell me and I go time yeah time
and mileage if you do eight [__] open
mics tonight I guarantee you 20 [__]
years from now you'll [__] get paid
because that effort will not be [__]
gone unnoticed trust me I'm telling you
you'll know too you'll know sometimes
they give you a check you look at it you
go that's for that [__] time my
finger bang that Indian chicken Twin
Falls Idaho on a triple run yeah triple
run would sing it all these things
you know what bro triple runs late if if
I had the time
I would take you on a two-week triple
run and hire you as the chauffeur just
so you see you know what you were tapped
by the third night no I love it I would
I would love it you know it's great I
can do them now I did one basically uh
earlier this uh or last year but I did
it yeah but it was a bus it was great it
was great I guarantee I wouldn't quit I
mean Lee this is but you're in a car and
you're driving 12 hours 12 Lee and then
you're driving and then the next day you
got to get up and drive another 12 hours
and then the next day you drive another
12 hours
and then Thursday you and you've
crisscrossed where you're gonna be like
you're gonna then you have to come back
yeah yeah you're in one that's crazy and
then you're in Missoula and then you're
in Yakima but Yakima and Wenatchee are
only like like Washington yeah in
Montana wait it's [__] crazy then you
gotta go to Lewiston and then you got to
go over to [__] uh Oregon and you're
in [__] Bay and then the next day
you're in Spokane you're like I drove
through Spokane five [__] times I
forgot all about Coos Bay Oregon man how
good is the [__] crab meat there
Jesus Christ no no no at least
I started one from Houston
took us into
somewhere in Idaho
and then we got up the next morning
because there's some days you drive
eight hours
there's something because you gotta
remember we got to do a show
so I get off stage at 11.
11 30. you gotta have a drink they pay
you you're gonna talk [__] these people
don't see civilization
they don't see anybody you're the
biggest thing that's coming to that town
since [__] the guy who shot the
president came in there
he's a pretty fun thing yeah no no no no
no it's it is crazy Lee and God forbid
if you do radio like you usually go to
some college station and you do radio in
those times they'll come out yeah you
really live in California
what's that like so you gotta talk to
them Lee so we're getting back to the
room at 1 1 30. we're up at [__]
seven five driving 10 hours to five five
thirty get to the hotel take a shower
eat do the [__] show go right back to
bed and [__] and do it all over again
hopefully we catch a six hour drive
but Friday you catch like a 10. and then
if you're lucky it's the same place
maybe an hour but don't bet on it some
nights you gotta [__] drive on yeah
yeah because because you got to beat
snow you got to beat the snow you gotta
beat the [__] and now you gotta drive
back home Saturday night after you've
done all that driving how did you do it
Joey without without the uh GPS like can
you read a map yeah [__] this
was
1995 Lee you bought a map you had a 50
state map yeah okay
my vision was a lot better than what it
is now
I tapped out once I moved to L.A L.A had
a different thing Thompson guy Thompson
guy that confused the [__] out of me I'm
no [__] Phi Beta Capper here I'm okay
with maps because I was a boy scout for
three or four days okay I was a weed
blow four five ladies yeah I was one of
those [__]
so something about my elders I'm in
Miami I learned how to read maps so when
I got into the triple runs you had to
get the state and drive it out and then
go to that page and put like a [__]
paper clip on that page in your page and
get the connector and then I would
Circle that and then I would get the
directions from them also they also sent
you directions they would also send you
the night of your gig and how you were
going to get there
so to the next gig so how you got there
let's say your week started Tuesday
through Saturday that's five nights how
you got to
to Wenatchee Washington that that's your
department that's your problem once you
get to Wenatchee Tuesday night
you're going to go to the place the Palm
Springs of Washington you just said it
before yeah come on Yakima Washington
and then you're probably gonna go to
Missoula on [__] now people like
Donna Richards in those days and the
other lady they had runs but their runs
were like four hours right that's not
bad
at all no those are the ones those
triple ones they were 12 hour run kid
and like what happens with uh weather
construction [__] you accidentally Let's
Pretend let's pretend
that there's a gig and it's seven hours
and it's me and Ralph and we're pretty
legit with each other and we hear
there's going to be snow
guys like me around for you go you know
what time it is no does and Mountain Dew
yeah might as well no Dozer Mountain Dew
pack the car back the [__] car and
right from the stage so we get right in
the car the hotel knows we're coming
we're Comedians and we'll get there as
the snow starts yeah by the time we're
getting to that City the snow starts
getting hit we're catching it as we're
driving at night yeah there's different
strategies something silly but how would
you find the weather out at that point
was that was it the TV radio yeah they
had the radio for all over the country
yeah but we also read the paper you know
that's I still do that I still like
reading the newspaper and it's like
Nobody Does it anymore
for the New York Post right at the
airport I rip it off because it's a
federal charge yeah right you know me I
want to be locked up next to [__]
what's his name for a week so I get some
info out of them maybe I'll call into
the podcast [__] El Chapo somebody
laughs
I wish my memory
was clearer of those times
there's maybe like three or four
prisoners
maybe five that I did time with that I
remember
from time to time their name will pop up
and I'll look them up on Facebook one
kid I found this son
oh wow and we communicated for a while
but I don't know what happened there and
the rest of the guys
like I remember edgy
he's a black dude that was like from
Indiana at the time with him he was cool
as [__]
Spencer Antoine I looked up first of all
if I'm 50 Spence has got to be [__]
80 because when I was 25 he was 55.
right so I was doing the time when I was
25. but I love to reconnect with him and
just talk some [__]
all the dudes of the AIDS unit they
gotta be dead that was 87. that was way
before the medication yeah and they
weren't looking too good then there was
a black dude in the 80s
they thought he was gonna die before you
know way but he made it by the time I
got out I got out of the halfway house
he was still there
when I worked with Katie Siegel and
Superior Donuts I felt like pulling her
over and going you don't understand how
many times I watch you in the age unit
that [__] show married with children
on Sunday nights oh yeah we get a bunch
of food from the visitations
and we'd [__] uh watch Married with
Children like eight prisoners and the
dudes who had the AIDS they wouldn't
they wouldn't leave their bedroom they
would stay in their bedroom but we were
cool with [__] with them bro we would
knock on their door and make them come
out and eat we used to have tons of food
man
[Music]
foreign